hello hello everyone welcome to this
session entitled from the map to
spatial intelligence my name is
didier gaubert i am in charge of
the business activity of google maps for
the international zone
we will spend 50 minutes together during
these fifty minutes we  there will be
three presenters i want to do the
first part of the presentation
then i will be joined by damien bon
who is the general manager of the
stuart company which specializes in
the transport of goods is what
is also called smae delivery
and who  would come and explain to you how
an intelligent geospatial platform has a
positive impact on its business finally
I will ask jean thomas rouzin who
is the founder of web geoservices of the
main map partners that we
have in europe to come and explain to you
how by exploiting mobility we
can generate micros  moments that
can be opportunities for
your activities or for your professions
so I never resist the temptation
to share with you what was in
2005 the very first beta version of
google maps so there you have
an image a screenshot
it was very centered on america
from the north
there was the british isles though
and i think since 2005
google has come a long way in terms
of covering the planet with with
maps so you can explore see
the world plays out from different angles
you can even go  visit
places not so easily accessible
which are that maybe we will never have
the opportunity to visit in any case
I do not know if you have
paid attention to recent news maps
but last week we added
in  google maps the certain
new planets of the solar system
so there for once we will not have
the opportunity to go there so google
passing in a few figures
its surroundings a little more than a
billion unique users of the litterateur
p  Every month,
200 countries and territories are
covered with
real-time information
and that's what you know from
google maps on the private user part,
but we have about two
million  websites or applications
that embeds google maps that embeds
google maps we started about
ten years ago with to deliver these
services for for businesses is
the purpose of this presentation is good
is to make you touch
finger how the platform an
intelligent geospatial platform can
bring opportunities in your industries
in a beautiful respective profession
so how google maps can help you
for your applications
the first thing I would like to
tell you is that google apps is good
more than one than a base of maps
it's a layer to give finally these
two multi layers of data which are
which are above here are symbolized
some of these data there is
the imagery that  can be
street view imagery it can be satellite imagery
aerial photo
oblique aerial photo which allows us to
present 3d buildings on some
major cities of the world or on skis for
example local information that's
what  'we call places on
points of interest we have listed a
very large number of places around the
world which are categorized
garages stations hospitals schools
shopping centers is safe you
have information on these places know if
a  restaurant is open that it is
the affluence of this restaurant etc etc and
therefore you have the possibility of having
access to its information to
incorporate it into your applications
for your own business processes so
quickly
how it works and well in fact  we
provide a set of web
services and cross-platform api so you
can integrate
on web apps on mobile web apps on
n apps  atives android or ios
so for ten years we have been providing
what our customers do I was
telling you earlier that we have two
million websites or applications
that use its services its services
maps I have  tried to categorize applications into five
into five parts so
historically it started with
real-time tracking visualization applications for people things
vehicles so widely used in
industries like logistics like
retail like transport like
travel like  such as real estate to
search for a property, for example, or
better billiers look at what is
around
another category of applications these
are internal applications so there
it is more often applications for
hobbyists decision or parties to view
on a map
it gives additional information
compared to a spreadsheet
compared to graphs so there it
is it is geo marketing it is
still logistics  that it's sales analysis,
for example, of applications that we
can qualify as companions, therefore
applications that give you I don't know
a thought of an insurance company
within the framework of these
automobile contracts that offers an application
for  assistance when you
break down you have an accident one by one so by
geolocating yourself you can pay
yourself you can call for help from
the app
it's also apps for
people who have
fairly serious health problems and  that in case of discomfort
or also can call for help
or if your cat is equipped with a
gps collar you can follow
your pet in real time 4th
category these are more imaginary applications
so here we are in the world
of games you  all know game of
thrones
or pokemon go cdu maps who is who is
behind and more recently we have seen
applications that took advantage or in
any case applications intended for
the inte  rnet from objects to
connected objects that take advantage of their
positioning and map data so
why I titled this
presentation of the map and
geospatial intelligence because we
see an evolution in fact of
what we can do and of and  the value
that geographical data and an
environment maps can bring
so it starts and I'm going to go very
quickly on this by gags by
paper maps so it even dates back more than
300 years
then about twenty years ago a
good twenty years we moved to
the digital world so we digitize our
maps and we can have access from our
internet browser to a map we
can see it in our on-
board gps system for navigation in our in
our car so there we have  a
more dynamic who's who look and feel and these are
static maps
so in fact these are maps that
represent the world as it
was when the map
was made  ruite that's why
ten years ago we arrived
in the world in the dynamic world and
the definition of the world of the
dynamic world and well that's why we integrate
real-time information in our maps
so  it can be traffic information
there is a format essential information
but once again where is
my taxi or and took me the delivery
of a package for example and more recently
we have two phases which are in the
process  to arrive we have to dance
the so-called intelligent phases under
predictive in fact they are quite a
lighter but for the clarity of the presentation
I left by intelligent phases
it is when you have literally
billions of smartphones or objects  who
are connected you want to know
where their smartphones are where these connected objects are
and you want to go further
than knowing what latitude or
longitude they are or even an address
you want to understand what is
around wanted to understand the  I feel that at
this position and I feel that this
position so for example this is what is
called the semantic knowledge of one
of a position example not sure
what it could be used for today but
today if  I look at my smartphone
it will tell me are you there does it have latitude
longitude at the 2 place wears jersey
but maybe it brings
value in your business processes to
know that we are in
the convention center in the room in the  room
number two and that on the other hand there is a
google cloud event this myth
unfolding
maybe it can provide
value for your applications for the
services you can offer and finally
the predictive phase is when we
combine all  these types of data that
I told you about
these data on the places on the points
of interest real-time
data historical data that you have that
we apply machine learning algorithms to it
and well we can answer two
to new questions
I will give you a fairly
obvious example that we do today
with google maps if in 15 days Thursday
afternoon in 15 days I want to go
by car from point a to point b I can
consult google maps  so that they
give me a range of time
how long it will take me to
complete this journey so we answer
new questions and I will give you
examples of three other examples
as this presentation progresses
so for  also make you
understand why we are in these
so-called intelligent and predictive phases I
am going to share with you three use cases
that you know by heart that
you use but just to make you
realize that behind in fact there is a
geospatial platform there  there is
real-time information that
makes it possible to deliver service and without
which ultimately we could not
do it
so if you go back 7 8 years
it was one of the methods  s to have a
taxi ride so not always
pleasant when it rains is today
of course we all use the same
kind of application whether for
vtc for taxis we use
an application a mobile application for
to book so if  you
finally think about it the
basic service has not changed it is
still passenger transport and the
way we interact with
the user has changed radically
and the service offered
to users is much better  and
you need one you need a
geospatial platform behind it to use trickery to
achieve this
another example when leaving the office
that I don't have the courage to make
dinner I stop there the pizzeria in my
neighborhood
I wait 10 15 minutes  by the time my
pizza is ready and I'm going
home today there is another way
to access this type of service and well
it is to use one of the platforms of
to order a meal
so one more  times we don't
automatically need this type of
platform but I chose pizza
two ways so as to say for example
around my house I have a
pizza chain I'm a fan of
brand x pizzas  there are three restaurants that
can deliver this pizza when
I call is fine when I call the
platform the platform will decide
based on the volume of orders but
also traces of
traffic conditions to deliver the pizza to me low
that it is the  restaurant at the moment t the
most able to develop me to
quickly provide me with my meal and a
third example which is quite North
American but which we see more and
more also in Europe
there we leave in the morning for work and we go
stop at the restaurant or at the
favorite café to have a
coffee and from time to time it looks like
this and again these service providers
have organized themselves to provide this kind
of mobile applications or when I
leave my home and well I  order  of
my coffee
and when I arrived two minutes
from the restaurant the restaurant knows it
prepares my coffee so that it is at the
right temperature I just learned
and I go home so
again there is a lot of geolocation
behind  real time to achieve
to achieve this type this type
of applications so now why
now why we now come
to those to this kind this kind
of applications and above all what types of
use can we have then the why
now it is  that in fact we arrive at
a combination of two
technological facilitators with geographical data
which is enriched
day by day, you
quickly understand how this slide
is organized so if I think of
facilitators such as the penetration
of smartphones
4g connections with ford bandwidth the ability
to offer geographical data where
we know how to guide you from point a to
point b to give you all the  t a lot
of reliable information on points
of interest or specific places and
providing you with information in
real time is obviously it can
manage new generate new uses
and impact the services or products
that you offer then  to
do whatever we see happening today
over the last two or three years
in terms of applications so we
still have our visualization applications
so I'm not going to go back to them
but we have things a  little
newer that we see coming the
first new thing is what we
call geolocation services
so it's not very well described
but that means we don't always
need  'a map of life and
shoes a map to
use geolocation I will
give you examples it is
the optimization of travel
since we have real-time information
on traffic conditions for example
so we can  play  r in real time
on this and then we gradually arrive
on pure geospatial intelligence and
I'm going there too the illustrated one so the
visualization I pass I pass
quickly by for the sake of time
geolocation services I took
the example of coffee but  in fact the example
of the cafe is an example of what is
called geofin advanced sign so that
means that we can define areas
and any object any person any
vehicle entering or leaving this area
will trigger an action  so there in
the example of the coffee I returned less than
two minutes from the restaurant it triggers
the action you have to prepare the coffee we have
the same thing with the internet of things
this example of one of the
smart thermostats connected
the thermostat or  in any case
the application that it controls
is when I leave work, given the
traffic conditions, will know
how long it will take me to get
home and therefore will decide at the right time
to increase the temperature.  e from my
home so that when I arrive it's
exactly the temperature I want
you also have another example and
it's far from exhaustive
sharing the position of objects so in
general we share the positions of
vehicles d  'a fleet of trucks or
people but what's the point of
sharing position of objects there you have
a printer I'll give you a
real example
think of the bread of the biggest
manufacturers of televisions of televisions
smarttv quota the first time  that
you're implementing a
baffo smarttv connect it so you
go through a number of
of the big setups to set
those connection items
it happens to be in a lot of
parts of the world depending on where and the
television
there is only one cable operator
operating in the area and
therefore knowing the position of the television
simplifies the configuration
does not need to ask for the
information  information to the user this can
be done automatically between the
TV and and the
cable operator's box so we simplify
the user experience he is mistaken
me there are fewer errors he calls -
the manufacturer's technical support which
which reduces  its costs that's the first
the first the first advantage for the
manufacturer of doing that the second
advantage is that in general
televisions well it's sold via a
network of distributors so the
manufacturer has no visibility on
where its customers are and in particular their
geographical distribution and
for marketing analyzes for
sales analyzes but also for optimizing its
maintenance service in terms of
spare parts or 2 or resources
knowing where its customers are can
enable it to optimize  so that's what
geolocation is also for and there
we are not talking about cardboard
we are sharing information have done we
know the position of
vehicle objects of few people
without displaying it but to make calculations
and in impact and your business processes what
we see happening more and more is
also the optimization of travel
is there for the next base testimony
will be a perfect illustration with
with Damien  but tracking objects so
we've
been tracking objects for a long time while skiing as
far as monitoring trucks or
fleets of vehicles is concerned, we've been doing this for 20 or 30
years but today we
're  also at a time when we have
new technologies appearing
in terms of low-cost connected objects
with long battery life
and therefore suddenly we can arrive
at a fineness or granularity
of objects that we want to follow  which can
be at the parcel level if the parcel has
a certain value for to track
to track these these items I'm going to
take a fairly recent example again
if you think of the
delsey suitcase manufacturers they announced about six hours ago
it month a
connected suitcase that offers a whole host of
services including knowing where the
suitcase is so when I go when I
board my plane I can know
in real time on my application if the
suitcase has been loaded in the same  plane
than me before I take off so when
I arrive at my destination I know if I
have a chance of finding my suitcase or
not so it's typically the kind of
thing we do today
real-time travel  I
'm not going to dwell too much on this,
however obviously now we know
how to make routing algorithms
for the management of delivery rounds
of maintenance technicians of
salespeople in real time in dynamics
to optimize their round so that for
whether it's more efficient imagine if it
wants maintenance technicians or if
your delivery drivers are able to
make one more visit per day the
efficiency gains for your
business
and that's only possible  ble thanks to
real time and we are gradually
moving towards geospatial intelligence
so it may not be very visible
on your screens
but these different animations
represent the movements of
google maps users who have agreed to
two parties to share their positions
in a few  major cities some
major cities in the world so its prices
over a period of 24 hours on a weekday
so in fact what it gives it gives
the home-to-work and work-to-home flows
during the day
and this data is
invaluable for  a large number
of actors so if you think of cities
if you think of
public transport operators people who
plan think of
road or rail
infrastructure carriers have this type
of information and listen carefully there room
and it allows you to plan  improve
and make decisions that improve
the lives of city dwellers and that's what
we call  geospatial intelligence
so it's when you
combine the real-time information
that a google is able to provide you
with your historical data and I can
tell you that in your
information systems you have a lot
of historical data that is
geolocated that you combine that
with
a little better knowledge or understanding of the
context
beyond a simple address to
apply machine learning and well you can
answer new questions or
make forecasts of
forecasts I tell you  gives a
fairly classic example in the world of retail
a retailer opens a new
store for you they consider several
addresses for opening their store
what is the best and the best
location to open their store
depending on the pedestrian road traffic in
the different places that  they
consider these kinds of decisions where we
can always have this information
by making  analyzes of field readings
but it's also data that
can be made available I'm going
to give you another example on
machine learning
it's a project we did
about 9 - a year ago with  a non-
governmental organization called the goal
phishing watch so it's an
organization that wants to give
data and tools to
government authorities on fishing in the world
and in particular overfishing in what we have
done  on this area of the world that you see o
screen in the north pacific every
day there are two hundred thousand boats
in that area there of the world how d
stinct have a fishi
g boat from another type of boat so that'
where  that depending on the
trajectory of the speed etc
then we are able to distinguish
fishing boats from other types of
boats and therefore over a given period
we are able to identify if there is an
area where there is too much  too many
fishing boats i forgot  é to say that the
boats all the boats in the world
give their position several times a
day so if we spot an area over a
period of three or four days where there
is an abnormal concentration
of fishing boats ebeya strong chances that we are
in  overfishing this information which
can be passed on by this
organization to the authorities who can take
the appropriate measures
so I come to the conclusion of
this of this first part it is
when you take all this
geolocated data that google could provide
that you have in your in your
datacenters that you have
computing capacities that you are able
to apply machine learning and indeed
you are entering into this
geospatial intelligence which really allows you
to rethink your
business processes to rethink the services or
functions that  you offer your users
or your customers to bring to
bring more value
here I'm going mandarin I'm going I'm going
stay here for now i'm going to
ask to bring a voucher to join me
damien is going to give you an illustration
of his job on his industry then
we'll have jean-thomas happy birthday
jean thomas and i'll come back for the
final conclusion thank you all
green hour thank you very much
didier for this introduction which will
be quite useful to show you
to what extent
stuart who is at stake you will present
the job interacts with the
google maps teams to bring the
most value to our customers
so  before i go into the details
of the stuart solution i just want to
spend a moment on the context
in which we operate we are an
actor in urban
delivery urban delivery is today
subject to two challenges first challenge is
for  our ecosystem
the cities why because we are
already in a dose of effort
urbanization rate in a region
like europe and it continues to grow
in  the peripheral regions of the
cities
the volume of 10 trade and in super
strong growth double-
digit growth and again for the next few
years
and suddenly we have a saturation of the
distribution
network a distribution network which is
today also poorly adapted to the
constraints  environmental
to give you an order of magnitude
in a city like paris we have a hundred
thousand delivery vehicles
circulating every day
and it's still essentially
thermal trucks today the
problem is that commerce
also changes the need for  transport of
goods
today end historically if looking at
the last 20 years we were
essentially in a year in paris
in the tooth of the replenishment of
traders today more and more
the share intended for individuals
of the bit or if they increase  and therefore it
requires it implies a less good
concentration deliveries in
particular the tendency to s  e have
a single package delivered
when the merchant historically
was more likely to have two or three packages delivered
so we are in the process of optimizing
distribution circuits and which are
also more and more
constrained so a real challenge for
cities a real challenge  to
transport them a real challenge for
the environment we tend to
talk a lot about transport mobility because
these represent 75% of
trips in the city against 25%
probably for
carriers for the transport of
goods, however this
represents  30% of the carbon footprint
40 to 50% of particulate emissions and
up to 50% of fuel consumption
paris reacts to has set
itself an ambitious target to
reduce the carbon footprint and in particular
diesel deliveries which  must
reach
the 0% threshold by 2020 on the
other hand we have a second issue which
is consumer expectations we have
more consumers  s increasingly
demanding that they appreciate
omnichannel the emergence of e-commerce and
what they tell us when we
ask them is that 83% of them want
more transparency in the same level
of  threshold of delivery slots
guaranteed shorter delivery
times therefore more instantaneous delivery
and that is a real impact
for merchants since 60%
today of purchases that are finally
started online are not
converted because of  a lack of delivery and even
when we go further in the
purchase journey and look at the famous
repeat we realize that 45 to 50% of
consumers who have a
negative delivery experience will not return
to the website  so
lange delivery is a real issue so
given that we know that it is an
issue for cities we know that it is
an issue for consumers what
is the answer the answer it is
in is what didier said
about intelligence space game  al review the
delivery circuits today and we
are stupid and of the consumer who wishes to
be delivered more quickly
we must first review where
the good is located and we have a lot of
data to know where the good can be
located we have  many have little use
and artificial intelligence that can
track your buying journey and
tell you if that pair of shoes you
have a high chance of wanting it
for the same day or for the next day
all these technologies exist and there
is also a  phenomenon which is very
important, which is the race for density
there is a phenomenon which is nevertheless
quite important, it is the increase in
the distribution network of amazon
today in the united states you have
almost one in two consumers
who  located less than 20,000 from an
amazon warehouse it's just colossal when you
know that amazon is still
historically not in physical distribution
it's an e-merchant so there
some quick figures  e amazon its 180
anthropo 60 not formulated for
local delivery and 65 advertising and that's the meaning
distribution network has been multiplied by five
with the acquisition of
two food roles which adds almost
439 distribution so we are in a
world today
swell e  -commerce is
meeting physical distribution and
so it gives plenty of opportunities to
review the distribution network once again
and that's where stuart comes in is
that we are an
on-demand delivery platform that  brings
flexibility to merchants the
flexibility imposed on them by
individuals so we are a
platform for merchants a ball
to be we are not a marketplace
as you can see in
companies like the ritz or books or
and  provided our services via either a
mobile application or a web
application or an api to be
directly integrated into the
merchants' purchase channel so why I was
talking about  flexibility because in
urban logistics
we are talking about lots of different cases of use
depending on the cost
the stock is located at a time t
the stock can very well be in a store
in these cases you will use it
as the point of  departure of your
logistics
it can be located in a warehouse
because you do not have a
physical distribution network or because for
some reason x or y you do not have
knowledge of your stocks in real time
and therefore you have to start  the
product from more than one or another
warehouse so we need to adapt
and suddenly the platform we offer
to merchants
makes it possible to respond to different
point-to-point use cases for food
or for a package that must be delivered by
express from the round
if you have more time between the
moment the consumer orders and the
moment the delivery starts or if the
warehouse is located a little
further from the consumer and we rest
well  obviously  t on a
multimodal fleet because we have to serve a
very small parcel as the funniest
as the largest parcel knowing that we
are very sensitive to the ecological impact
we obviously try as much as
possible to favor green means of
transport  like the bicycle, the
larger capacity cargo bike
or electric vans and of course we
geolocate our couriers in real time
thanks to and in particular with the link with the
google maps teams the cases of use
will go very quickly on that because
I  prefer you talk about what
very concrete use so we make this choice of
leaving in store or leaving in a
warehouse we can even use the
stuart network to exchange one of the
goods between two of its stores
we can push a return on demand
this  that we have just developed with
zalando to allow
a consumer to
return their parcel over a 15-minute slot avoid having to go
to a post office or
pick-up point  s
we can offer the same experience
for merchants what we call
on-demand collection
instead of going to the post office is
to close the store for two hours
for an internet purchase
on the other side of the country eh  well he
presses a connected button to
pick up for a race they
pick up his package in the media so
I'm going to quickly go over that 3 3
interfaces for which we can regret
a courier of course a
mobile application a web application for those  which
have a slightly more recurring use and
the country so that the rocket to the
courier is directly integrated into
the shopping cart
after the selection of an
express delivery so ex-store we have
been working with carrefour for a year
which  allows who can deliver
today paris and its near crown
from a dozen stores you
go to a site called
express delivery - carrefour.fr you
order you select a li  vre and
a 30 minute delivery window and
you can follow the courier in
real time so all that I leave you to
imagine to what extent and I will
come back later we can use the
google product suite to help
us offer the best experience
possible for the consumer
the second use case for a customer
whose launch will be announced within
a month is evening delivery the
same day to their quest how is
the distribution network going
you order online until  at 3
p.m. which is a kit of time why
orders are prepared in the warehouse
then the order is sent to
local warehouses for a
cross-dock operation which is I
receive I sort and I organize my
rounds again in real time
to  evening deliveries between 7
p.m. and 10 p.m. and all traced you can
follow the race in real time
so it allows merchants to
launch a delivery on a d day again
u  sometimes you have up to 13 14 15
hours depending on the location
or the warehouse for an
evening delivery so we are really
changing the way delivery is done
with a much better
customer experience for a pram  the same you have
a package that you want wanted to
return to zalando you go to
the alonso application on
the indo website you select return on
demand 15-minute window you have
a courier arriving he picks up your
package he leaves it  in relay point
before being brought back to the zalando warehouse of
course it is a service that is highly
appreciated by consumers with a
strong will have a very good return of quality
of service for precisely the simplicity
and the speed of execution
then  how can google
help us so we use a
number of google tools I
will name a few the first is
the javascript country that allows us to
our application  web that you saw earlier
to display the map to show the
location on the map
and it is also something that is not
necessarily very important delivery
which is the auto complete addresses
for the address  be as precise as
possible which will be a great guarantor of
the quality of service on your side
after we also use static sma flat
country to display the place of pick-up at the
end of collection and delivery in
the customer's mobile application in
the  'courier application an api which is
strong it is one of the most useful for
us it is the direction application'
as its name indicates it allows us
courier applications to indicate the
direction it also allows us to
calculate  the exact distances between the
delivery point and the
collection point of calculation and the exact way ittihad
when we search for the
potentially closest courier
in our optimization tool it is
not the only criterion but of course  a we will
look at where the geolocation
of the courier is in relation to the collection points
we can use the distant country matrix
which allows us to calculate the distance
between the collection point and all
the couriers who are eligible to
take the race and  Egypt because
they are available to sue or
eligible because they are
finishing a race in a
very close environment and finally the
geo coding country the geo coding apei allows us
to translate all the
addresses  in latitudes and
longitudes which are of course the
coordinates which allow us to
run our
route optimization algorithms so once again it is a
very useful support for us
so all of its services
today allow us to combine  of
course to the intelligence infrastructure
that we are going to add on top of offering a
real game schenzer I would say in
the delivery sector which will
allow us to bring more  no
more predictive traceability as didier
mention it and so all that honestly
it's
extremely easy to use and for us it's really
finally a tool without which we could
really work efficiently
good I'm going to end with
that suddenly c  is the guarantee of success
when you have a service that is well
executed other today we work
on a certainly with a certain number of
customers
on almost all vertical then
of course the food and the food is
a big part of  our business but
we expand quickly on retail
with the customers that the customers
you see there on the different use cases
that I have of course quoted the
service for two years and we are present
today in France  in england in
spain in france to give you an
order of magnitude we are present in paris
in lyon in bordeaux montpellier toulouse
and we will open
at the beginning of next year a
certain number of cities and appear  in
spain and england
so i will now let
jean thomas speak for us who will
talk to us about web geoservices thank you
hi everyone so jean thomas or jt
it's easier to remember so i'm
jean thomas i founded  web geoservices
then what is
wedge in the service it is a company
that is dedicated to the location intelligence
of consumers not from where do we
have two that we left goes from one to  a
trend when you look at the google
trends over the last four years
an extraordinary growth in the
request
around me, that is to say that there is a
really extremely strong appetite
for the consumer to know
what is happening around him to have
contextualized services in relation to its
location
I'm going to say to myself it's not a surprise
it started about ten years ago now
thanks to google maps in
particular to make the blinds
look wrongly history the foursome is
obviously  to find  the nearest store
with opening hours
then when retail started to
really go digital and we passed
the omni-channel phase so we
went from looking for the nearest store
to looking for the
closest product  with the stock available
ok all that is totally related to the
location of the consumer and his
environment
so my presentation will revolve
around that
and ultimately help how we
can help companies integrate the
notion of around me  in their
business that it really concerns
all companies so I talked about
look blinds wrongly closed products
quator look stocks wrongly and that's
what didier asked me for for 7
for this press it's  go
into detail on uses that are a little
more innovative and more technical on
how to use google maps as a
database and which will make it possible to
detect what are called
momentary microphones everyone knows  ait the micro
moments of google how to
finally use the location of
consumers the google
maps database to detect these famous micro
moments and start to interact
with the user
so we started to work
in the world of the web is d
help companies to
geolocate their users on
their websites and adapt their
services at the time apps were a
bit neglected for a while we started
because it was often a kind of
replication of the corporate website
of companies  today we are
in a trend
we are also returning a little bit to
apps to provide services to our
users services to offer the
service at the right time the right person
we have to make people know how to detect these famous
micro moments and all that finally goes away
of a value proposition
so it's me and now I am
I really want to say more and
more to the company  ise who
wants to talk to me ok I lend you
my geolocation data I
share them with you it's in your interest to be
careful
I'm counting on you to respect the
rules of privacy 12 hours of these of
these data and in exchange I would like
that you are smarter with me I
would like you to offer me services
in relation to my location profile
and the value that I will seek
has finally saved me
time it is a question of logistics
ic personal compared to the  previous presentation
and then obviously to allow me to
find to have access to more good
plans more offers compared to the
way I move but place of
short life in fact my life my life of human
beings so here this  what you see
on the map
that's my all but geolocation that
i shared from for a week
time a little bit we you see
i went to the south of france
around them in the var exactly i
am  went to montpellier there we have our
our r&d but we also have offices in
milan this week there I spent a
few days a few days there
so I'm going to show you a little bit
more in detail how it works and
how we're going to come across this  information
with google maps so what's the point
how can we bring this
intelligence to the trades all
companies when we're going to be
in finance
we're going to help improve the
payment experience detecting fraud
in insurance the pay  as you drive,
i.e. paying for insurance based on
my actual use of the product, which is
insured, inventing new services
in retail, of course, means
bringing smart push notifications
and spam and
users send them less  advertising
but much more
engaging messages is much smarter
at lower frequencies but a
much more efficient conversion rate
of new services
mobility of travel assistants and finally
also things on which we
work a lot it's on the gaming
experience gaming you all
remember so maybe still remember the
pokemon go users in the room
it's the use of a  map
the digitalization of the world is above
the game scenarios me who moves
around in this environment
catching pokemon so
great is that google maps is an
extraordinary playground for
cross-referencing the location of your
users of the mediators of your  apps
is finally all the services that
you can offer them detect these
famous micro moments we forget we talked about
there in the previous presentation a
lot of real-time traffic routes
calculations calculations of distance
by road on foot by bicycle in public transport
what we are starting to exploit more and
more now is the description of the
world found in
google maps, that's all  s these points
of interest which are present in there
in the database and which cross
with the location of the users will
reveal a lot of things about their
behavior the places they
visit
so how does it work
but we will use the  location so
collect again respecting
the rules of privacy of
course and then we will segment in
relation to the environment of this
location with more
or less sophisticated algorithms try
to analyze what is around
the user  and here we are going to look at
all that in the pee wee base of
google maps and the base is called google
please here it is a base which contains
several hundred million
now from two countries with data
refreshed at a very high rate so  with
high quality with
descriptive information inside
the genre type of country type
service type opening times these
lands so i will pre
to feel a demonstration to show you a little
bit
what is the potential of the use of
this data crossed with
geolocation data so well that to
switch directly on my computer
so what I share with you here
on this map  is a live map it is
ultimately a tool an internal tool
that we have on our on our products
in my back office but which allows you to
view all the geolocations
that are captured on my on my
phone on my mobile phone
you see that  that's a lot of a
lot of data so first of all in
the world in the google world we can
process now
astronomical volumes of data by helping the
conference google cloud google
cloud that's the point to collect to assemble to
analyze volumes of data
extraordinary so here already nothing that we
visualize by visualizing this map we
see immediately where are my centers
of geographical interest so
regularly I go to ga  re from lyon
I tell you a bit about my story but
regularly I go to the lyon train station
you can guess the path I take
to go to catch my train
you see that around here there are a lot of
green dots that's where I  I live here a
lot of green spots this is
where my offices are in paris i travel a
lot we have offices located in milan and therefore
offices in amsterdam in london and
often we also go to streets of london
it is the headquarters of  google google's headquarters
in paris so that's the
data we collect
just by putting it on a map of
course now visualize what we're
going to be able to do is ask for a
program and an algorithm to look at
what  is below its
geographical positions and trying
to write automatically to give
meaning and the semantic element that
didier was talking about earlier and
this is the meaning they want was in the
google maps database
so  actually if i zoom here you  see
all the points
all the points see it even the platform
on which I took my train where
I parked my scooter on the sidewalk
but a place where I had the right
and then all the services that are
nearby with  from which I am I have
gone and little by little we will be able to
characterize so it is interesting
it is in real time characterized in
real time what is near my
users that he visits a station that
takes the ring road to go  to the
station characterized all the places
where I pass by to return from paris
we guess them we guess them on the map
the place where I live the place where I
work
and here the place here soumah under my mouse
which is quite  interesting it's a
place where I go quite
regularly and where I'm detected in the
morning between 8am and 9am in your opinion where
am I sorry I'm dropping my
daughter off at school
here it's also a micro moment  this
is really the meaning of my of my
presentation it is  st to show you that
when we start to cross the movement
of human beings
once again that their consent the
goal of the game is to offer them
services with the cartography of the
digitized world and all the information that there
is in a  base in the
google maps database well we will be able to
start detecting microphones moment
so make sense and offer
services to your users in the
form of push notifications of messages
and what do I still know you have to leave
room  creativity on this subject
so obviously we see that I am
now at the palace at the
convention center this data is really
totally in real time and that
not very long ago I took the plane
to go to  munich here is where I am
today on my
location profile weekend switch back to
death lights part thank you so the in
conclusion in conclusion of this of
this presentation
it was the idea it is to put oneself in
per  perspective compared to
the presentation the previous presentation
in ten years google maps and therefore the
digitalized platform of the world in
which there are data
services tools to calculate distances
to finally optimized but also to
describe the movement of humans is
finally made a world  much
smarter finally transformed
our applications are in service in
application which offers services
I give the floor to didier
thank you for your attention
[Applause]
thank you very much
jean-thomas thank you very much to jean thomas
and to damien for for their testimonies
I  would like to quickly give me a
conclusion we have seen on the I mean
the last five years one one of
these industries which have been strongly
impacted influenced or even disrupted
by new entrants
I am thinking in particular I am thinking of the rites
she I am thinking of the logistics at
transport to the world of work to the world
of real estate to the world  de taxi ride if
you think of taxis there are businesses
that were created in five or six years that
did not exist and that today
are businesses that make
billions of dollars in
turnover so  cease these industries
have been disrupted or impacted low by
new entrants mainly
because these new entrants have been able to take
advantage of
real-time geolocation and we strongly believe that in
fact all industries that exist
including the most
traditional ones will  being in turn and
you as I was looking for memo is
such that you thought
about 15 20 years ago about the advent of the
internet the advent of e-commerce
he thought about what it was for you  could
positively impact what opportunity
you could seize thanks to this new
communication channel as you
are currently thinking about
the opportunity of the public cloud in your
digital transformation
you also owe yourself  to think about
your geolocation strategy you
have I assure you a lot of
geolocated data in your
data centers think about what you
can do with it what new service
you have created what service you
can improve in order to create
new opportunities for  your trades
your respective activities